so before we get to the album guys a
star on Music City Walk of Fame I mean
that's that's pretty cool
oh my gosh we yeah we were I mean so
blown away by you know them wanting to
give us that and then the biggest thing
was we didn't know who was inducting us
so we were like you can you know our
team were like do you want to know who's
gonna be there and we're like no let's
just show up and be surprised never
expecting in the world that it would be
Tim McGraw yeah and so he just got up
there and had a lot of really funny
things to say and a lot of really nice
things to say and I'm a Nashville native
so that just to have that star forever
printed into that ground is just it's
such an honor and just to be in the
company we are with all the other stars
that are there it's amazing is that
something you're gonna bring your kids
by and be like we actually did for the
ceremony we brought all of our kids down
there and they were all blocking all
over and we were trying to get photos
and it was a disaster but yeah it's
gonna be fun to take our families there
I mean something that permanents pretty
special huh what kind of concept you
have of what you guys do I don't know
maybe they're grasping a little bit more
but I mean Eisley hilary's is sick so
she probably gets it a little bit more
than ours but I think they think every
parent you know travels on the tour bus
well and we I just try to be really like
mindful of just you know we all we all
go to work and go to our stage so to
speak like you know in in that it's just
more about what doing what you love to
do doing what you feel like you're
supposed to do and and she though does
now every so often be like so my new
friend said that they heard your song in
the radio like two times over the
weekend and I'm like oh my gosh that's
awesome
I'm really glad they're playing it but
it's it I just love that we can bond
over music that's I think that the
coolest thing that I've discovered with
with Isley is just she's such a music
lover and we have that in common
and so it just continues to just build
our bond which is awesome
yeah I mean what do they think of the
new stuff I guess they're the real
critics right yeah
I don't say Mack my kid he's three and a
half he loves the single what if
he calls it never get over you I'm like
what what's what if I never get it would
you like he likes that and you look good
one of our songs from a few years ago
yeah there's song called pictures on the
album that my daughter same ages
Hilary's twins she would just always
sign more more pictures and some more
pictures but it's fun day it's funny
they love all the new stuff I tried to
play need you now for my son even didn't
have any hair decade now do did you
expect it to be what it is do expect
Fame and all of that to be what it is
for you guys man I mean you always when
you start I mean you have big dreams you
know but you don't really know we're
really fortunate to I will say when it
comes to the fame it's like we're known
it's like it's the group when we're in a
group setting we're all together it's
different you know but I can still go to
a store and maybe get recognized here
and there but it's it's not like you
know Taylor Swift walking down the road
so I feel like we kind of are really
fortunate that we get a little bit of
best of both worlds you know but I don't
know I mean at times it's a little kind
of weird to think about it but I think
like what Hillary said to wake up and do
it you love I never thought I would have
a job that like I literally wake up and
I'm like oh my gosh like what could
happen today like what song could I
write today yeah what will the show be
like there's just so much to look
forward to in it yeah I mean you guys
were you have this story about being
backstage at the CMAs I mean my question
about that is like given the things you
guys have do you still run into people
and and feel starstruck yourselves yeah
yeah I mean we we were just at the same
as this past week and I mean pink was
there with her husband and their two
children and we live with Halsey yeah we
meet her for the first time yeah it was
pretty amazing and oh absolutely you get
starstruck but a Dolly Parton of power
that's the epitome yeah yeah yeah so you
know your fans have a real relationship
with your music over the course of seven
albums I mean who wouldn't right well
we're here Oshin is here and what's the
response been so far what's pink right I
mean we've you know I think what we felt
so much is that we tried to lean in and
be a little more courageous and
vulnerable
with our lyrics and I think that's what
people are resonating with I mean that's
what they're identifying with they're
finding their own stories and what if I
never get over you finding their own
stories and what I'm leaving for in the
song ocean and finding great inspiration
Redemption and be patient with my love
and let it be love and there's just been
a phenomenal response that you know we
were a little kind of like alright maybe
we should go deep go a little more
vulnerable on this album and we feel
like that's what's connecting this time
around and so we're thrilled to hear
that I mean this record I don't know if
we could have made it 10 12 years ago
this is a something that's kind of
taking a season of life for us to live
through and to write about to be here
yeah this is not the party album a
different kind of party but you know how
do you decide that that's what you're
gonna do collectively it I mean it
honestly happened very organically and I
think us just not fighting what felt the
most authentic to us in this season and
a lot of it started with Charles writing
a song on the record called be patient
with my love that truly was the song
that we built the rest of the album
around and he just that song is so
introspective and vulnerable and brave
and and so we kind of challenged us with
it in a way well I just think you know
to the best song wins and we did start
to create a theme of that of that
honesty and you know our last record was
had a lot of fun songs on it you look
good and and you know and and more of
that party feel and it just felt like it
was time to kind of return to a lot of
the sound that we had on the first
couple records you know there's a lot of
the fans were saying this does sound
like a return to the needy and how album
and yeah and that's kind of what we were
going for yeah you're on stage
collaboration with Halsey has been
getting a lot of attention it was a very
cool thing to see do you think about any
other artists out there that you go okay
we got to do this now we got to work
together
we there's we have a huge wish list I
mean obviously you know people like
Timberlake Beyonce I mean that would be
you know nuts
I mean Adele I think would be at the top
of our list but you know I think for us
we just I don't know it all like that
the way that thing happened was just so
random and it felt so organic you know
and that opportunity came about and you
know the songs mesh really well but you
never know you know like on this record
too we have a collaboration with little
big towns first one we've ever put on a
record and so I don't know he you know
we were even talking the other day about
how cool to be down the road to do a
whole collaborations album take note of
what a Sharon did you know making a full
collaborations because it's just it does
I think spur on new creative ideas and
the juices flow in them like what you
can do and different and how the
production can shift and change and it
would I can't imagine how much fun that
was like I love that album of his and to
think about us being able to do that at
some point would be awesome
little big time one it was a long time
coming it was yeah I mean we've been
talking about doing this for a long time
now we've been on the same label you
know we were on the same label for a
long for many years and they've they all
go down to place in Florida that we all
go down there to the beach together and
hang out and luckily I found them all
the day they had been drinking all day
and I said alright we've talked about
this but we're doing it and so I made
sure they put it on their schedule and
here's a really deep yes like we do but
there's some of our best friends I mean
it's been finding the country music
world it's just one big family reunion I
feel like people love each other and
there's some of our best friends in the
industry so it was fun watching their
process of doing harmonies and then we
expect our harmonies I mean so there's a
total of seven voices on a lot of that
song so it was pretty special
you